one year ago we adopted the first ever
eu strategy on the rights of the child
and as part of it the european child
guarantee now let's hear from the
children
and one of the main aims is to make sure
that all children
get equal opportunities regardless of
their background or family situation i'd
like to know whether the children are
included in deciding the strategy and
actions we will launch our child
participation platform this year and
present many other initiatives for
children and young people this year so
we are doing what we promised you so
having in mind the humanitarian crisis
that has emerged
from the russian invasion in the ukraine
do you believe that there is a need to
change the way this party is allocated
what we need to do is make sure that
enough funds are allocated both to
ukraine to the ukrainian children and to
the countries welcoming the ukrainian
refugees helping children in this war is
a top priority for us and everyone in
the commission is working very hard on
this i am convinced that the actions in
the strategy of the rights of the child
can help improve the well-being of
children all children in europe will
have access to child care education
school trips healthy meals at school
health care and adequate housing we will
leave no one behind
[Music]
you